o me o life of the questions of these  recurring of the endless trains of the  faithless of cities filled with the  foolish of myself forever reproaching  myself for who more foolish than I and  who more faithless of eyes that vainly  crave the light of the object mean of  the struggle ever renewed of the poor  results of all of the plotting and  sordid crowds I see around me of the  empty and useless views of the rest with  the rest me intertwined the question o  me so sad recurring what good amid these  o me whole life  answers that you are here that life  exists and identity that the powerful  play goes on and you may contribute a  verse  Walt Whitman